ami malone
33 year old left-handed making his fifth
start he's one and two with a four era
18 innings pitched 22 hits his fourth
start today the month of august has not
walked a batter
change up there and down goes curiel
got him
got him with the changeup second
straight two up two down
both strikeouts
changed the angle and threw it by him so
tommy malone strikes out the side in the
first inning tanner
heads up the back side of the bump
to make the start for the blue jays his
fourth one two to santander
left field
and it's down for a fair ball into the
corner
cisco into third base santander's got
another extra base hit as he
jogs in with a double wow an excellent
opportunity here in the first inning
second and third nobody down three in a
row though now 12 and 11 on the season
there's a ground ball to third and
they're coming home and they will get
the out
that's a terrible base running play
unbelievable in the first inning
and the 3-2 swung on and missed that's
out number two
and the 2-1 to alberto and a ground ball
up the middle but an easy play for the
second baseman jury and how about that a
base running mistake helps out and
randall bridchick leading off slider
swinging a high fly ball out to straight
away center field mullins gets back at
the wall he runs out of room it's gone
randall bridgick has just sucked his
fifth he has homer in his fourth
consecutive game
and the blue jays take a one to nothing
lead and the orioles have two on nobody
down for the second straight inning
[Applause]
and rohar gets him on three pitches
smith out at second valenca at first so
most catchers in the big leagues now are
programmed before they step on the field
threw him another fastball and he gets a
pop-up drury the second baseman the
infield fly rule is in effect and there
are two down
out toward center field a couple of
strides to his right randall grichik is
there and he puts away cisco alberto
with a lead off double to start the
fourth
i move the guy to third base there you
go good job line drive base hit right
field alberto whoa it gets by the right
fielder going all the way to the wall
smith around second
all the way to third and he gets the
stop sign and stops this time jose
flores gives him the stop but a boot out
there by oscar hernandez i told you ben
i was watching their game sunday and he
kicked one around in right field and let
this one go all the way to the wall
which should have been a single now has
the orioles with a run in and a runner
on third nobody down
yes you can there's a base hit in the
center field
and smith can walk in rbi for valleca
and the orioles go on top 2-1
infield has come in for the blue jays
already down a run right behind
it in the air to right field and not
very deep hernandez coming in to make
the catch the runner is coming home the
throw on the fly they got him
so oscar hernandez who committed an heir
earlier in the inning makes an
absolutely perfect throw to the plate
to gun down a runner and retire the side
now exactly the guy you wanted to play
if you're the blue jays in this
situation agricus hit the ball hard
twice today the first one a home run
high fly ball to left center field it is
well hit and he has done it again
another home run for randall grichik
his second of the game and the blue jays
are back on top how about a series of
the beltway
for randall grichik he's homered in all
three games
against the orioles shaw works the walk
and up comes the red hot randall grijic
richard out in front a little bit but
he's hit it to deep left but it'll just
stay in the yard a couple of feet shy of
the fence one down and now brandon drury
with a chance to increase the lead for
the blue jays here in the eighth there's
a fly ball and it'll be deep enough
mullins will make the catch shaw will
tag
and he will score on the sac flies the
blue jays take a two-run lead there he
is gotta catch his run in big run down
to third base swinging a line drive base
hit into right field here comes biggio
to score and the blue jays have a 5-2
lead on an rbi single by lourdes gorilla
jr
and he is going to bring the tying run
to the plate after the walk
and he got him
delise picks up the save and the blue
jays come to baltimore and sweep the
series and they cooled off a red hot
team they really did a great job of
pitching randall grichik he did all the
offense man he is red hot and he had
four home runs in the series including a
pair of home runs this afternoon